for like I'm all about the long term
this is my game plan I'm on my last long
term it's my last contract yeah maybe
I'll [__] negative Hall of Fame you
realistic but if I'm out of this yeah
this one's over once this tour is over
I'm out of the game forever dude I'm a
bachelor until I'm 55 I just gotta keep
it in shape that's the bachelor thing
yeah you gotta stay in shape it's a fat
55 year old Bachelor doesn't get any
closer so you're preparing for your
eventual breakup no I'm putting
everything I have leaving it all on the
field for this one so that I have no
regrets if it happens no regrets
what's that uh are you gonna reference
movies no one's ever seen you've seen it
I've seen the trailer I know the scenes
it's this movie I don't know yeah the
trailer got around everywhere we are the
Jones
sorry
is that uh one of the we are the Millers
I think and that's based off the Ben
Stiller franchise
Fockers is that from a Fockers no this
is everything
do you think that uh oh well we're on
cool you turned it on uh
just the sound yeah hey Paul can you
stand up and on that side there's a
little button a black button on the far
side let's just tap it
what is wrong with this picture
maybe it needs more curtains
nothing happened
oh yeah yeah there we go I'm gonna try
to curtain it out more curtains yeah
how's my ass look you got more curtains
out there look at your asses right oh
look at that dude my fat ass [__] out
I got my ass again bumped into more
recently do you think it's because it
got fatter like I'm like notably more
gets bumped like what do you mean by
fatter oh people touch it like people
have been groping me more often like
it's more luscious or I think it's
sticking out farther are your glutes
some people like stubbing their toe but
like they're the back of their hand you
know when you walk into something as you
thought it was like maybe it's like
where do you choose to stand maybe you
have a different like mentality and the
way you see social situations right now
you're putting your your ass worse kind
of guy right now maybe you're throwing
it back you know yeah do you see the UFC
fighter who went to throw a spinning
King and just turned into spinning ass
you see that highlight
I don't think so this guy during like a
knockout sequence he went to throw a
spinning kick and he jumped and he just
went ass first in the guy's face so it
just looks like he just didn't ask so
like a ass attack ass hook yeah yeah
it's like an E Honda
you [__]
[Music]
sound like Godzilla just kicked on yeah
it's really Bassy with these headphones
on
each yeah dude a little Lone Star huh
yeah
um dude Sunset looks nice the room looks
nice you went and did it already it was
the best job interview I've ever had in
my life which makes me think I'm not
gonna get the job because every other
interview I walk out being like there's
nowhere they're giving me that [__]
job this one maybe this is the one job
that uh you did correctly and all the
other jobs were like shitty things that
they just had to do yeah I hope but guy
is it the same club owner do you know
the long hair guy he seems nice
yeah the long haired guy I can tell why
it's called Sunset because I didn't say
this to him but I was like you're into
80s metal 100 like I met that dude I was
like in the 80s you loved hair metal and
that's why this place called I think
it's like Sunset Strip or whatever
that's my take on them so drop in
reference to 80s metal band while you're
there if you want the job yeah did you
no I just spotted it from a mile away I
just know those guys I'm like this guy
loves Van Halen he loves [__] Journey
yeah the old school Northeast guys
are like that a lot because they're from
that place and they have a lot of
traditions there and
they grew up with that there so a lot of
you I bet you hung around a lot of those
people yeah also 80s hair metal was just
such a moment that like you that's why
there's so many it's like Nirvana you'll
see kids wearing Nirvana shirts now it's
like that was like a huge moment we
can't even like relate to it no band
today would ever be this big do you
think it's because he blew his head off
or Courtney shot him in the back of the
head or something no because there's
like two media outlets at the time
because it's like Tupac same argument
was really great but like he died and I
think that infamy kind of
so with Nirvana same thing yeah I can't
really you know the hip the Hop I don't
really get it the hip I don't really get
what they're doing over there put a
guitar in a guy's hands you know what I
mean put a shotgun in his hands and
where's the keyboard it's in the
tambourines and the guitars you know
stuff us white people like
like REO Speedwagon or something like a
good triangle
yeah a nice high pitch frequency
electric uh Light Orchestra right they
have a triangle on there
do you guys hear about Diplo
what happened he said that uh
he's more than likely gotten a [__]
from a dude before
what does that even mean he was on a
podcast with Emily rat record whatever
her name is
hopefully he's related she's hot but uh
she asked him about
they were talking about blow jobs and
then he just volunteered that
information
and it was like I think I've probably
gotten a [__] from a dude before
that's what he said and she was like
wait you've gotten a [__] he's like
yeah but I don't think it's gay unless
you make eye contact
and and I don't know but he said he's
not not gay that was what he said after
imagine living that kind of life I can
remember first last name in the zip code
of every girl who's putting her mouth on
my penis that's how a few of them never
been oh man the sketches out there not
even knowing the gender he's like 44
though and he's been famous for a long
time he's friends with uh Oliver
North Stone or whatever no Oliver the
the pop music artist the young guy
Oliver tree Oliver tree him and Diplo
but hanging I think yeah I saw that I
[__] with Oliver tree yeah
everything's a joke to him yeah isn't
that funny though
well that's how that industry works too
whenever you're hot you can hang out
especially the pop like music genres
like of course I like that someone's
just not taking it too seriously he's
just like yeah I just put out like a
good track every so often it's kind of
good though yeah it is good it's very
catchy this is not over thought yeah
that's probably the key to its success
it's just literal energy and uh with a
little character of that character yeah
you gotta have a character dude South by
Southwest that's just so many music
[__] burnouts on the streets playing
music right now like everyone just sits
outside be like this is gonna be my
moment I'm gonna discover because I'm
busking during South by Southwest
but they're not they're just gonna
continue to do yeah under behind I
thought you had it hugs like this yeah
and then the right side if you can go
more behind the camera yeah there you go
that looks pretty good you have a little
bit at the top
but other than that I mean it's not that
bad okay it looks pretty good yeah I
mean I think some people just like
busking they don't have to be doing it
for some insecurity yeah that's true I
might be putting my own insecurity on
the buskers
sometimes I walk by a buscar because I
do I'm a man of many towns I can play
little drums little guitar and sometimes
I look at buskers and I say if I get am
I gonna be better than you or you're
doing you should be out here
what is a busker
you got a band I got a house
like an Elon musker
okay
are you an Elon musker
are you back are you back oh watch your
camera dude
[Laughter]
uh it's like Cloverfield right now
go go we're gonna get out of here I made
a for my from my TV prod in high school
I remade Cloverfield in my high school
basically that because because my idea
was it's so much easier to film
just the stupid Handycam shot and it
would be to make like a TV broad file
from high school people got sick from
Cloverfield yeah theaters I guess I
liked it bunch of [__] I watched it
again later because I saw it in theaters
in high school and really enjoyed it oh
yeah
damn TJ Miller was the king of just
rolling up collecting the bag and just
and just randomly in a lot of things
yeah dude and like David crossed me in
the Chipmunks the Alvin the Chipmunks
like it's so it's so sick just to be
like I worked so hard for comedy I'm
gonna cash in one time and I'm not gonna
give a [__] about it
is that what I did or did it do he did
Alvin and the Chipmunks I think I think
he was one of the main voices in it he's
done a couple of things he was in uh he
was in Eternal doubles too was he wasn't
he um David Cross
John David Cross
TJ Miller oh no but I just switched it
over to aircraft yeah because I want to
talk about our good community no I like
uh not his new special with the mask but
I like meticulously ridiculous whatever
that one was he has a mask special he
has one where he's wearing a welder's
mask the whole time yeah
and he flips it down sometimes one of
his physicals
David Cross is an Eternal Sunshine CJ
Miller yeah David crosson oh he was like
one of those shitty friends he used the
shitty friend trying to smoke weed with
him it's awesome dude that's what I want
to be I want to be in a movie it's like
Todd Barry and Louie you just roll up
yeah yeah that's the that's a dream
comedian Joe I don't want to be Dave
Chappelle I want to be tall like Todd
Barry or you'll never be him as far as
stand-up guys as far as appearances and
stuff I could be that yeah yeah for sure
I feel that you just want to like just
be included two days of shooting and
you're in a legendary film that people
say is their favorite film of all time
and you're such a small part they forget
that you're in it I didn't remember he
was in it yeah
yeah it's all about a bunch of friends
helping friends though too like if you
think about it like Jonah Hill and
James Franco and Seth Rogen and all them
are all like in a lot of the same movies
stand-ups get a lot of that [__] too
because people have like an affinity
like an actor or director will be like
it's so cool that you do stand like when
Tarantino just hangs out The Comedy
Store yeah
and they did he like loves it so much
doesn't realize that like it's just the
shittiest rfo it's like the lowest
comedy it's really not good
what's up
damn dude we got Richie Valens coming in
here with the sideburns right now wow
look at that Richie balance watch out
there's wires
now it sounds like we're in a helicopter
right now
it's worth it
hello everybody hello hey it's Mariano
what's going on
not much who are you who am I
uh I'm the person you invite on this
podcast I'm a comic here
and how much more of an introduction do
you need do you not really feel like
describing yourself right now uh uh yeah
I could describe what's your sign you're
more of an ass guy or a tits guy uh
honestly I'm more of a tits guy I like
that I think tits are coming back I like
I think fake tits you faked fake tits
fake I love it I love fake tits once you
get a certain age or you know yeah yeah
there's an a stand-up clip of Seinfeld
where he's like you ever try to be
honest with a woman and then he goes
like your rear end is too big
and I don't think anybody says that
anymore there's like but like that Peak
ass is turned in the 90s they say all of
a sudden people wanted access now you
got a fat ass no I'm gonna ask man I
think yeah there was a definite historic
Trend towards nice small bumps as butts
yeah and then we started being less
racist and we're like oh wow these are
way better South America and Africa got
something to bring to this whole
equation yeah my mom would always worry
about her butt is my butt too big she
would ask but she's Argentinian so we
want to be white so that's that's why
she was worried about it yeah
Venezuelans are argentinians I always
are like you're trying to tell me you're
trying to pretend you're white right now
I know you're not
I'm technically Mediterranean brown but
nobody gives me credit for it I'm a
colonizer myself just do you have the
23andMe
I don't but I just I I just very much
assumed that my family didn't have sex
with any indigenous people because my
Spanish side of the family like half of
it is Italian which I can trace back to
idiot
and then
then
you really can't talk I guess I can I'm
just saying I assume my family's kind of
bougie so they wouldn't they wouldn't
tell me if they had sex with someone who
was indigenous in the family lineage my
girlfriend Bobby one and I never took it
and sat around for like two years and
she gave it to someone else what someone
else came in it yeah here's mine my
girlfriend not the someone else came in
your girlfriend yeah then I said I don't
want her it's a gift from you your
girlfriend's at 23andMe yeah you just
come in her mouth and she switches it
around she's like yeah because she's
from New York city so she's really bad
you know she's got she's tasted all the
cups
she's got avian flucom yeah swine flu
just on Subway's licking polls
pre-diabetic she can tell you you know
she's really good yeah
Scotland dude I heard when Asians do it
it's just like you're Korean 100 there's
not a lot of data on it yet oh that
sucks that's never been enough yeah then
they'll keep your DNA and tell you if
something comes up later yeah like an
update so you could like not be Japanese
right now and just because I had my uh
brother's wife they found out that
they're significantly more Japanese than
I thought and one of the girls in their
family had like a mental episode about
it because yeah because genetics are
important well no yeah exactly but she
was like that means we have trauma in
our pet you know what I mean whatever
she was just feeling it all of a sudden
she had to invent trauma because she
took a 23 in me yeah she did she wasn't
aware that those countries knowledge
knowledge knowledge induced trauma yeah
that's funny but it's like hey you did a
lot of trauma I don't think Japan really
suffered that much besides World War II
and earthquakes and yeah I think that's
what I think she's feeling guilty she
was like now I know how white people
feel because she was like Asian
privilege yeah I guess I don't know
yeah Japan really uh try to be white
they thought in all the worst ways sell
my [__] up for so long it's crazy well
privilege is relative it's weird to
bring that up that there's like
hierarchies among like in South America
it's the same thing people think
argentinians are racist but then here
they're like oh you're just Mexican so
it's like who cares you know like
nobody's you're the tallest [__] yeah
exactly that's what I would transcribe
myself as
I'm five eight so I think that's that is
more about like no I know I know I just
made it about my height yeah it's more
figurative yeah I know yeah you are
short I'm self-conscious about my height
if you can't you've seen those shoes on
Instagram and give you like two and a
half inches I have not the cartoon boots
no they might be called heels
stilettos is a good brand try doing drag
dude if you just didn't say it in your
Star Wars heels on stage like one of us
like especially like you not maybe
everybody knows yet there you would get
booked more because they'd be like I
don't know I think he's gay or something
it just never represents you're like you
start getting put in like don't talk
about it top 10.
yeah white guy in heels
that's appropriate oh this is actually
getting a little too close to reality
man are you getting turned on no I'm
thinking you know maybe some people have
kind of tried that angle oh yeah just
being like hey I'm straight but I'm
gonna do one thing different with my
wrist and then I'll say I'm gay and get
booked yeah yeah and dude there I don't
know you know everyone maybe it could be
like Mark Norman after every set be like
thank you I'm gay yeah they're like oh
why don't we have him on our gay show
yeah well you know we gotta lift up
white gay voices they're really
important yeah I mean yeah yeah they're
the most annoying of the gays they're
the America of gay people well these
young white gays because old white gays
I can rock with you know yeah they've
been oppressed yeah they have to go
through AIDS especially southern food
like is like is a whole nother dimension
for anywhere I'm from like you know the
80s if you were in the South okay that
must have been like a [__] nightmare
yeah seriously that's why I like Austin
everyone you meet that's old and gay in
Austin they're like yeah I lived here
and then I just couldn't anymore they're
just like you can't be here anymore the
only place we can go to is Austin it's
like the only place within 10 hours
drive that we could live in the [__]
80s I see a lot of old people but you
don't see a lot of old case yeah they
all
got
um you know the biggest thing with AIDS
now is just the the fact that you can't
let like it's just the social stigma of
it because it's pretty much cured yeah
I'd rather have herpes than AIDS
no man wouldn't you don't you mean you'd
rather have anything like nervous is
that what you're trying to say no I I
agree because because the herpes yeah
because herpes would show AIDS at this
point it's just
it's just like a [__]
it's like being Argentinian no one has
to know about it unless you shout it out
I feel like yeah I feel like I shouldn't
I feel like Magic Johnson I feel like
there's been a cure for AIDS forever
Magic Johnson
when he got he had enough money they
gave it to him and then
and then they it got quiet for a while
and then Charlie Sheen got into it yeah
I was gonna say Charlie and then they
were like [__] all right if everyone
probably forgot imagine could be the
anomaly and no everyone knows Charlie
Sheen if he lives long enough they're
gonna be like how it's like just Charlie
Sheen apparently had some crazy ass
doctor though that like did some weird
[__] it was like on red bird no it was
not comrade no okay Benjamin Franklin
the hundred dollar bill he had but he
had like a some like doctor that was
outside the scientific mainstream who
did some crazy [__] so
I like people that lead with I'm outside
the scientific mainstream like it's fine
if after I know you for a while you tell
me that little people lead with that
when they're like one thing I don't know
about me I'm outside of the scientific
mainstream that's never a good thing
people lead with free speech too yeah
true just I don't need to hear that it's
like yeah that's the best thing about
your speech is the ability for you to
say it then that's probably not the best
yeah dude Hans is a [__] oh yeah oh
[__]
in the mic I can't [__] miss that
thing that's a ping pong ball oh you
missed them dude
he's fighting back oh there it is those
are so much fun I bought one too it's
[__] Epic
[__]
it's about to attack you dude that flies
about December the same fault uh death
is my grandfather my great grandfather
it's crazy how much of a difference it
is as you put coarse cool kosher salt on
it it really kills them the jewishness
the jewishness
the Muslim bugs
approach yourself so what do they do to
the Salt before they say it because I
can understand Kosher meat it's got to
be prepared a certain way what is not
Kosher about salt you rub the rabbi's
foreskin okay
three thick cheese okay yeah three times
in The View
say a prayer kosher us all be good if
you're a cocaine Jewish cocaine dealer
kosher salt I don't know that was better
okay I really feel good
yeah I was ready I was going to close in
that one yeah
like Jewish drug dealer yeah so many
kosher salt I've tried to write a joke I
just thought family my drug dealers are
feminist sometimes I didn't think of a
setup and then I can never find I have
my drug dealer is a lawyer because that
was true and then I had my drug deal as
a feminist because that was funny and I
I tried maybe 50 punch lines for each
one never got anything was your drug
dealer Lauren more of a lawyer or more
of a drug dealer he was more of a drug
dealer it was like you know doctors
don't make as much money as you think
some lawyers just are not if you're
working for like the state or whatever
you're just representing like people
that don't have any money you should not
make any money and you have to sell
drugs on the side there's probably the
bit right there actually so he was
selling to the people he was
representing was he like a public I
tried so many angles on that yeah just
to be like he had to tell me you don't
know your client in court and be like my
client he goes by Trey no I mean uh I
wouldn't know that yeah I don't know
big big money Steve I mean Steven donzer
now I fronted him a million times and
he's always paid me back he's a
trustworthy guy he would never steal
yeah
you think it's easier to be a lawyer or
a doctor
lawyer well listen to schooling I mean
there's plenty of terrible doctors
just like I'm doctors of you're like in
an ER or some [__] if you're just like
yeah different type of well it depends
on what type of doctor I'm just talking
about to get the doctor title if he was
looking at feet all day actually you
just want to get the doctor title you
can just get like a master's in
sociology it's really [__] easy you
just like look at Stats and say Yep this
is bad that's what I'm saying I think
it's easier to be a doctor and then you
offer a solution that they'll say
they'll just push aside so yeah we'll
try that you guys ever walk by a
hospital and just see doctors and like
just chilling it's so weird because you
don't realize it because they're always
you usually see them when they're fixing
something that's important to you but if
you just walk by a hospital my sister
works at one and they're just [__]
hanging out not doing [__] you walk they
walk out the front they're just sobbing
they're just taking their mask off
covering blood and then just crying out
to the sky yeah they're just I lost
another one
Sam like that one I don't think that
they care of it really I mean you get
too emotionally attached like people die
all the time in the hospital you know
damn dude that's sad dude every day like
right now someone's probably dying at St
David's open [__] been away I can't
even well if you're gonna die you're
gonna go to a hospital so that's where
all the Death collects yeah that's what
I'm saying so how do they deliver that
bad I can't even deliver bad news that
we don't have the new Tangerine Dream
like we're out of it at my work when I
could tell a table after they've ordered
it I'm like I can't [__] tell her
well yeah that's a hard job it's like
George Clooney and up in the Airways go
fire people for a living yeah it's like
who has the job of military personnel
that has to go tell the wives and family
that their husband died that's gotta be
one of the fuck-ups like that guys to do
it every day they probably give you it
once you [__] up like when you back into
something and knock it over you know I
mean the guy just screws up around oh
you [__] knocked over the porta potty
go tell
you know donzinger his wife that he's
dead it's like the worst guy
yeah he's like the [__] all over his
hands his flies open yeah he like bumps
into the door yeah he's dead oh sorry
I'm at the wrong house can I get a water
yeah can I use your bathroom
uh any military uh parents in the room
what what does that mean I don't know
military I'd like to know if people have
military parents because they're usually
[__] up people I am not a parent but I
was in the military I mean like uh your
parents were in the military no okay he
doesn't care if you were my parents were
not in America I thought you were saying
is anyone here a military parent no no
yeah that's weird I don't have a child
anyone here in the military do you have
military parents Paul I do not I don't
know what did you what were you trying
to lead with I just like what were you
trying to find out about it
yeah I have a military Uncle I have a
fluid Chopper in Vietnam and she doesn't
not talk about it ever yeah it's
probably killed a lot of people oh 100
just being like is that them no oh my
bad
Sam was a Sam was in the chillitary yeah
I was in the Navy I was on an aircraft
carrier I did I was in the aviation side
so I heard Navy on a boat no okay guys
what other stereotypes hey gay guys I
wrote all the branches that's true yeah
so you were on about flying
you're doing two things that humans
don't do yes I was a ift in flight tech
on these
to call the e2c Hawkeye and it's the
radar it has a big radar Dome on top of
it so anyway we're tattletails short
skinny your snitches yeah we and so I
get those little aliens that like is it
similar to what happened off the West
Coast they they got like the track of
the [__] aliens Tic Tacs everyone
said yeah the Tic Tac ships is that like
you see any aliens yeah no no I can't
say that I did damn just uh just my
buddy and balls in your face
[__] dudes
Moby Dick I think it's like prison well
if you're on a submarine it's not Moby
Clan it's Moby Dick there's women in the
Navy I [__] and they're gay they're
lesbians not all of them some of them I
mean they are well everyone wants an
education a lot of people there was an
influx when I joined there was a influx
because people just wanted to get free
schooling so you had there were some
baddies and and you know I thought about
joining the Army to get one of those
sweet Challengers that they give you
they give you a challenger or a charger
the Air Force has they don't give
anything the air force uh they give you
PTSD the Air Force has the hottest
chicks though I think yeah yeah
Marine probably has the Amia has the
least Navy has I mean they're not that
hot in the Navy Army's better I'd say
Air Force Army
well you don't really get into the
military to bang chicks no no you get
into it that'd be the only reason
well maybe like people that aren't in
the military yeah yeah that's true you
don't [__] where you eat or [__] were
you did you guys ever watch that HBO
program about the brothel in Reno Nevada
Ranch they had Air Force Amy Air Force I
remember 84 savings yeah shout outs to
Jean-Paul Rivera because he's a big fan
of Air Force and we've talked about it
he's talked about it doesn't the guy die
though
I remember being so fascinated by that
show I would watch it on HBO on demand
yeah it would jerk off and then still
watch it after I yeah yeah which makes a
really good television yeah taxi cab
confessions after I finished jerking off
I wouldn't watch it anymore that was
wild yeah that one was it was all fake I
think I think some but I don't think all
of it my girlfriend watches uh the one
of the only points she watches the fake
taxi performance she likes fake taxi
porn which makes me concerned every time
she gets on an Uber just like she wants
to [__] yeah for sure why does it always
have to be involve danger it's so weird
with the serial killer documentary too
just that that's a weird Turn on there's
no dangerous fake taxi it's just as
women are just frazzled nerves they're
like all the time and then they're like
hey that's the only way I can [__] is if
someone's [__] killing me yeah the
lie between being reported to the police
and being incredibly sexy is like such a
thin line sometimes foreign they want
you to sleep off their feet but if you
do it a second too early all of a sudden
yeah it's all about knowing when to
violate their rights yeah because they
want them violated yeah
violate their left so violate their
rights and I mean I think that's
everybody everyone wants to like crash
into someone and not really be in
control because otherwise you'd just be
alone if you want a complete control
yeah that's true I want to like be swept
off my feet and just be dragged into
some relationship and just be lost in
another life in another world with
another person so do you think when
that's so sweet Hans I want to get on a
boat with you and just [__] yourself you
like to go to Galveston you like boat
sex hounds if you had a lot of buses my
ex-girlfriend uh had I found out that
she got arrested because there was a it
was like a police log and she was like
trespassing where was this police log
Here I Am the the police station no it
was like in the newspaper okay and then
like 2 A.M she got bust on a boat with a
guy it was like a week after this is
your current girlfriend no my ex oh okay
yeah she got a rebound on a boat yeah
that didn't belong to them so which is
even labor it's like you're gonna [__]
on a boat these [__] the guy owns it but
the guy owns the boat will probably [__]
you yeah I mean that's why he has it
yeah yeah they're not even using it yeah
I think you get a boat to [__] yeah
that's fair so they just snuck onto a
boat and the alarm went off yeah or I
don't know they [__] too like I was
probably [__] way better than I I
mean she hadn't had good sex in quite a
while on the scene so she's probably
getting her money's worth that's
probably drunk which it probably was
pretty fun dude I haven't had sex on a
boat like that but that would be fun
what do you mean like
yeah real believable
and girlfriend oh wait he didn't mention
she respond I believe I mean uh
ratajowski
read a tattoo I would never [__] a
jowski whoa yeah anything ends in ski
I'm out but although Russian Jews I do
[__] with mostly have had sex with
Russian Jews in my life that's like most
of the partners I've had where do you
meet your women Russians well they're
like America
and get [__] by a loser no yeah it
sucks for them it feels like they're
back in the gulags when they're with me
it smells that's probably about as bad
yeah it smells like borscht why does
Jordan Peterson always talk about the
gulags like anyone give us
that is so funny he had a tweet where he
was like Chachi PT describe Trump
describe Biden you had 80 words for
Biden and 50 words for Trump therefore
bias own dude computer and it's like
what is this guy doing now God you get
shorts isn't it like you get too much
too much attention like everyone like he
probably deserved the amount of
attention he was getting like 2015. you
know what I mean and everything after
that's just like way more that he
probably ever bargained for yeah no one
needs that much clean your room like
clean your room is like wash your balls
like that kind of advice is only helpful
to a certain degree you can't make like
changes to the [__] political system
just by washing your balls every day
also it's not true I just got a
girlfriend that does all that for me so
I don't even need to do that [__]
anymore it's like that's the Andrew Tate
yeah you just upgraded for Jordan
Peterson I want that Andrew tape too
Jordan Peterson on steroids yeah yeah
everybody at hans's show every single
person in the audience confirmed that my
girlfriend cheated
yeah and other people podcast check it
out oh right and then uh that was like
you guys and we found out they're
[__] each other or whatever like you
guys all [__] and then I said my
girlfriend I didn't have money so she
went on one of these trips alone like a
year ago and I was like do you guys
think she cheated on me everyone said
yes there was even a black dude in the
front who I was like having a good
rapport with and I was like did she
really and he's just like sorry man yeah
and I was just like [__] yeah did you
bring that up to her uh yeah I said 200
people I lied I said the sold out
the Moody Center uh they said that you
should have man they were like but they
don't know me and I was like wow that's
true yeah she didn't have time to work
her womanly yeah hypnosis on them but
it's okay you know what I mean you think
she could have convinced him I was
talking to I forget his name he got
pulled this week on kill Tony he looks
like me he's funny long hair he's like
got a beard yeah so we were talking
about our girlfriends we have long-term
girlfriend I was like you're right she's
like cheating on you like I don't know
man if she did she did I can't I used to
work I mean as a dude you're not gonna
have as much sex as your girlfriend in
your life as available anyway so it's
like I'm already operating at a lot
she's already had more sex and more
opportunity than me so what do I care if
she's had one more and if she's not if
it's been long enough yeah that means
she cares about me enough to hide it
yeah and I can't sabotage my
relationship based on like oh like a
weird paranoid you know you just got to
be like I really hope she's not but if
she is I guess for what what that the
only reason is like because you're
you're like at least one person has as
much sex as I have yeah so if this
person is having a little bit more fun
than me then I'm gonna feel really bad
because I thought this level of fun was
okay but she's saying no you're not
enough yeah so it's like oh is this not
enough but then that's like do you have
fun like why does it matter if someone
else was having more fun than you yeah
it is illogical the whole but I don't
think I could ever do like a real open
relationship with someone why won't you
let me [__] your girlfriend
it really doesn't matter dude she
started reading the [__] book by the
guy that goes on yeah and she didn't
know I was like she was reading sex it
now she bought it and she's like you
know this he says this and I said you
know that guy's been on Rogan like five
times right she's like what and then
like the next day never saw her that
book ever again and I was like finally
the world the women Rogan hate it
finally has paid off dude so you just
like [__] yourself out of a polyamory
relationship dude I don't that would
never work even if she's mentally
healthy most of the time there will be a
day where she's in the dumps and that
will be the biggest fight ever yeah
about that so if she's doing it too
though you're assuming I think in that
scenario she's not also even if she's
doing it even if she's doing it I do not
think and it's fine if anyone else
thinks that they can handle that but
there's no way I mean we're so happy
that it but like we're not gonna
withstand that type of we already have
like little issues that prop up you know
is sex in the bathroom at a bar on
during girls night is that does that
count I'm I don't know like I said if
she can keep it from me without no well
I guess I don't know it doesn't hurt me
yeah I think the positive side of that
trip to Mexico was last year right yeah
so you're good it's been a year yeah I
don't think she's cheated on you since
well she just flew to fly I just think
she absolutely cheated on you Mexico she
just flew to Florida this morning so
because her sister is in the hospital
that's which is which sounds like a
really valid excuse is she though yeah
yeah do you have the proofs yeah so
hopefully we're good totally take a
selfie no there's a selfie at the
hospital
live stream her sister location is like
it has I guess he has a debilitating
it's really sad actually that's what she
says yeah I know debilitating illness
where she can't stop sucking [__]
but uh yeah so are you worried that
there's bad genes in your girlfriend's
family maybe we're not gonna birth a
child me and her okay but why would you
yeah
because unless unless I had like a
meteoric stand-up ride where I had
enough money to do it it'll never happen
because it's just I refuse to have it so
the only thing is the money uh or like
on the case of an accident then I guess
and I just that's my lot I'm like I was
I want to ask this question earlier when
you're talking about the meeting someone
and not planning the whole thing or
whatever uh do you think moments in life
have you heard moments in life where you
thought it was like a sign that you're
there and do you think that's just
something humans tell themselves because
it's like a good narrative and you kind
of build it up in your head and like
work harder or do you think there's
actually like a force in the universe
that may occasionally like
you know hmm does that make sense
I just it's like life just happens at
moments so it's like not really like
uh helpful for me to think about that
yeah oh is this being controlled or not
yeah yeah you know striking is like a
very sentimental guy in that sense that
holds on to a lot of relics or just you
just kind of go like oh I haven't yeah
it wasn't in the Navy
he's holding on to a row like the first
condom of the guy
his name was Tony he was very gentle
it was very dark how many Italians are
not in the in the Army because I think
they're gonna Uprising you know there's
a Filipino Mafia in the arm in the Navy
in the Navy in the American Filipino
Mafia it definitely sounds like these
that [__] each other it's for real I
think yeah they promote like later yeah
after Thailand Filipino is the biggest
[__] place right yeah yeah like I'm
asking you like I don't know I think
yeah I mean they're both I guess equally
probably but I've been to both places I
saw uh I'm sure I would have been
tricked a couple times I didn't [__]
anybody but it's not called tricked when
you were into it right
dude some of these lady boys like
because so there's this I forget the
name of the strip I was in Phuket and
there's a strip you walk down and it's
like bar it's like an alley and then
you're just boys he's gonna Focus
yeah
that's what because non-binary you're
gonna [__] it that was the joke the
whole thing we were like I don't know
but [__] it yeah
I saw a good Snapchat compilation of
this guy he was in the Army and he's
just drunk as [__] and he's on the
street of some country yeah in Asia and
he's like I don't know [__] a [__]
tonight and these guys are around her
and then he cuts and he's just like
sucking her dick on Snapchat and he's
like blackout drunk dude and you know
this guy he posted up there and then
probably deleted it he's a guy who had
like a lot of Snapchat followers for
like posting crazy [__] in the Army and
just was a party party dude and dude I
don't know maybe he totally owned it the
next morning he's like I don't give a
[__] but I think he was just blackout
drunk and posting like what could be
drug posting yeah I think that guy
considers himself gay you know not at
all
like it's somehow straight if you're
into transsexual porn like if you're
interested that means you're Clinging On
to Your heterosexuality no it means
you're not a thief you're just taking
what you need from the store huh you
know what I mean this is what I need
right now so it's like a lot of steal a
little bit of bread I'm not proud of it
but you know yeah there's so much it's
saturated you don't need it's like it's
not like that's it's not like you're
when you do something it's not like
you're in prison and you get a random
box of porn to watch forever and you
just so happen to get [__] porns
you're like
I'll watch it I think maybe that's
exactly what would happen if you're in
prison for 30 years with no other
content I think 25 years in you're like
I guess I'm just gonna jerk off the
training probably less than that it
wouldn't take anything you're ever like
I'm tired of women like just rejection
and just unpleasant behavioral brains I
just want someone that I can chill with
that also looks like a woman but none of
the other parts
uh I have a there's a joke where at the
end I spell like dating a trans woman I
say yeah your girlfriend's School My
Girlfriend plays OverWatch so I don't
give a [__] about and no it was kind of
a niche reference but it's true like
trans women so yeah do you think like
trans People Are People
well yeah
but like what about like people that are
like really into their gender like is
that like normal or weird it's like why
are you that into like being a man like
they're like I'm a man and if anyone is
another gender that they're not born
with and you're not like me so I'm gonna
hurt you yeah that's true there is like
a weird level of I don't know but there
are those dudes or just are dudes
they're not in any way trans or anything
there's a lot of very just masculine
dudes who are just [__] yeah
I saw a dude wearing a dress the other
day and I was like it's that is a dude
where I dress that's not a trend it'd
look like a guy who thought it was funny
because you don't see it very often
anymore where a guy thinks just wearing
a dress is funny and I could tell the
way he was goofing around his friends
that I was like we found this I think
they were like moving by his face yeah
apparently there used to be a classic of
British television yeah they were like
comedy and they was not they were movies
or something and they found a dress
that's like this is what I put together
in my head because it was just a
masculine dude wear a dress anyone could
put on a dress yeah over his mover's
outfit not just movers oh yeah it over
is moving he had like coveralls with a
dresser when you're just dancing as I
drove by and I was like you don't see
that idea very often like yeah no it's
like a whole political statement yeah
back in my day we used to be able to
dress up like women and just do it for
the fun of the game yeah just goof
around no you have to get surgery if you
show up dressed like one for Halloween
now it's like a big it's like the new
blackface for Halloween they're getting
rid of it I think which is silly because
it's like shouldn't I I don't know I
think it is I think people take it the
wrong way yeah a lot of trans people
don't like it because they're like
you're my culture is not your prom are
you saying that you dress up like a
woman is that what you're saying yeah is
this what you're doing pretty much so
it's trans it's trans women not
biological women or whatever
they complain about it it's mostly just
for hits you know people that like to
[__] on people because uh they were
never invited to party so they're like
hey you're doing it wrong yeah yeah I do
wonder if like those people who are like
complaining about Halloween costumes
online would actually like if they were
in person at a party if they'd actually
have a problem to be like hey yeah
you're [__] dressed as a Native
American definitely not uh Shane Gill
stole a story on a podcast right after
he got canceled they walked by the SNL
line like people waiting to get in and
everyone just stared at them and they
were all like like kind of giving them
like looking at them and then on Twitter
later that day somebody was like I saw
Shane Gillis outside and I yelled at him
and I said [__] you and all this [__]
and he just read it it was like this
literally never even came close to
happening nobody you felt that way yeah
you felt like he said that so that's
what people do with [__] like that
they'll like in their head you know the
please clap or uh there's that Reddit
that happened or or slash that happened
where people posted screenshots of
people talking about the crazy story of
how they were heroic or whatever
that's like
so what do you think about communism
the EA old famous question uh let's see
top three Communists I Gotta Give number
one Pol Pot I think he's pretty good
Lennon yeah
yes yeah
I died in a jungle in Bolivia you got
screwed by Fidel though where is Bolivia
come over where is Bolivia
right near Bolivia Uruguay it's next to
Paraguay it's it's right above Argentina
it sounds like a European country yeah
they got really [__] they landlocked
them okay so it's like uh what's the is
there in South Africa
no it's it's just is there another
country inside South Africa or is that
like it's not official oh Botswana yeah
Botswana is inside a country okay yeah
that's [__] with countries even kind
of Portugal and Spain is kind of you
know they have the coast yeah I just
know this from like Risk and
civilization that it's like shitty to be
yeah it's still the yeah most cheap way
to get lots of goods to place like ocean
costs nothing to get things across
really you just put so much [__] on
there that's why when that that shipping
thing turns sideways it was such a big
deal yeah so Bolivia got really [__]
because they just literally just they
they're the most they gotta airdrop
everything yeah everything in Bolivia is
this width of a plane holy [__] there's
nothing wider and it's not usually
countries are like that because of a
population density issue but for there
it's just that getting [__] to the
country well they carved up South
America I'm sure like they carved up the
Middle East yeah they know the it was
Chile it was South America so what
pissed them off about Bolivia it's what
was the what was the rub they're mostly
I know they're mostly indigenous except
for like a German population they have
the the ruling classes like German white
yeah it's pretty weird it's always like
a thing you can point to be like well
why do these guys get the shittiest part
because they got the uh slantiest
foreheads yeah they had a a guy who's uh
kind of socialist who got was a native
and then he tried to Morales yeah he
tried to make himself permanent elect
leader and then the white people kick
him out again and now they're like the
crying socialism and communism I kind of
don't like I'd like to see a James Bond
movie where it's just him like
assassinating political leaders like not
evil guys
functionaries
oh welcome sir yeah spreading like
propaganda and [__] about him everywhere
yeah he just kills Kim Jong-un Daniel
Craig yeah Daniel Craig I think the best
James Bond has been Daniel Craig Obama I
do like that Pierce Brosnan though I
mean just because of golden eye when I
was a kid playing yeah we're spoiled
we're used to men that look like [__]
adonises back in the day they didn't
have the diet they didn't have the
exercise Sean Connor is red like all the
time yeah he's the reddest guy he didn't
know about rock cancer or livers yeah I
think Paul Pierre uh Paul Paul Pierce
yeah Paul Wall Paul Bronson was uh
Charles Bronson what's his name oh
Pierce Pierce Brosnan Pierce brosno okay
Pierce Brosnan was just a different Bond
he was like a more pretty boy
for sure but Daniel Craig is like a
believable
James Bond as well no no bond isn't
believable and I was like this skinny
white guy I just feel like if you were
James Bond you would that would be your
persona you wouldn't talk much a real
James Bond would be like [__] a real
version of who's the really Dan
Bilzerian but not his like shtick like
that guy or Jocko will like it would be
that guy for real yeah cause that guy
doesn't stick out in a crowd like I
wonder where my assassin is probably the
beautiful GQ model coming at me so it
should be like Ty Gwen
janitor dude Ty does appear next to you
when you don't expect like you're having
a rough time in your life and for a
while when I moved here I was doing a
lot of drugs I had a moment where I was
really high I said does anybody else
like is Tyler wind just talking to me
does anyone else see him is he my
guardian angel just appearing and giving
me Sage advice all the time and like
floating away and he's like he's just
like the person he's the perfect height
for a guy you would imagine in your head
as well like yeah it's just a very weird
I saw him I saw him at the other night I
saw him out somewhere like really far
away then I went back to my house which
is like a 20 minute drive and then I
went to feed Terrace to pick up stuff
for my girlfriend and time to win
another guy walking down the streets
yeah and he's never gonna be like oh my
God goodness he's like oh of course
yeah yeah yeah yeah my girlfriend
literally says uh that he's got a tunnel
underneath Austin yeah I love his post
on Instagram because a lot of people
that are posting like Sage spiritual
stuff it's really eye-rolly but we're
tired just like every time I read it I'm
like this is actually what I needed
today it does like okay money man
[__] inspiration you need [__]
he's like Zen Buddhist mixed with rapper
with [__] boy he literally is like a
king of the hill was like he is would be
a character and it came with like itself
like when I met him I first moved here I
was like these are the people I moved to
Austin Texas to interact with it was
people like this that are just so weird
and so themselves like yeah like it's
old I apologetically he's lived here for
a while I think right yeah he's a native
can you stop grabbing the mic arm
like it's a dick or like it's an AK-47
they were trying to fight against
imperialism who's the best one of the
best South Americans let's start with
women what are the who the hottest
person Salma Hayek
Brazilians gotta watch out for later
boys as well though now like fat ass
ladyboys yeah watch out for ladyboys in
Austin like dude Brazilian trans they
the dick that flops out of their [__]
bikini is will scare the Dickens out of
here dude scare your dick right off yeah
I'll become trans yeah it's like they
[__] you yeah they're more of the tops
yeah you know Tyler they got the bottoms
but yeah for that I'm more of a Central
American I think I go north south like
the north of South America for my the
women that are Columbus you're saying
Colombians yes yes yeah Colombians are
hot yeah Venezuelans are very hot too
yeah Miss Universe is a big deal in
Venezuela they like room girls to be
Miss Universe oh my God that's what
happens if you live right there
destitute country it's like they should
probably be like you better learn to rap
and play basketball do you guys see the
when Steve Harvey called Miss Universe
wrong yeah like that was so wasn't that
like like fake though no no I was for
some reason watching that with some
friends yeah and it was literally like
oh just they called the lady wrong and
then he opened commercial and he's like
oh this was actually this person one by
turns out it doesn't matter it's all
judges voting like when because no one
gives a [__] about that [__] so it's
truly that happens no they do and they
do in third world countries dude really
oh yeah sure yeah my body is worth
something even though my mind is not as
much as like [__] other countries
talk about America like if you can be
seen in America or like yeah sort of
make it on a global scale that's like
the biggest thing it's like the [__]
entertainment Capital still it's like
Civilization it's like oh you made it
into the world
and uh it's like if there were aliens
watching us but like oh you wounded onto
the galactic stage yeah did you hear the
Pentagon say that there's a possible
alien Mothership in our solar system and
that they've been releasing
you may be nervous I saw you notice that
I was tightening it
dude wait when did the Pentagon say this
like last week probably when something
else really bad they didn't want you to
know about half and I mean I'm sorry to
be that guy because I know it's like
it's not it's not a good distraction
it's not a new idea like I hate when
people bring this up and act like dude
it's a distraction like oh I've never
thought of that but they could do that
but it does seem yeah I mean Pentagon
officials suggest alien Mothership in
our solar system could send many probes
to earth like that balloon thing
literally happened like two hours after
the Ohio train crash and they were just
immediately like and then like dude the
drag uh Queen's reading books in the
library every time I see them say why
the [__] would anyone care like I get
there some people you see it on the news
or do you just see it on your phone
because that's what I think about
sometimes because I get all these
dresses on the news yeah like that was
covered ways so the point was like if I
was in the local town this would be too
much coverage and I could understand
people having an issue with it in the
local jurisdiction or wherever it was
happening but to have it on national
news it was just like this is this is
the stupidest thing there's like
multiple conflicts going on all around
the world right now talking about the
Chinese balloon the drag queen readings
books to kill anybody who gave a [__]
one way or the other like he was like we
gotta fight for them I was like no we
don't it's a little it's like four
people that are kind of weird like let's
be honest they are a little bit weird so
yeah and then the other people it's like
the places in Southern countries where
they're like we have freedom but you
can't dress like a woman yeah it's like
why not but it's like uh yeah what else
are we gonna argue about this is like
the peak of our you know it's like a
word problem it's like a cultural math
problem it's like what do we allow what
is the okay to do and it's like it's
it's a it's like the next step instead
of gays instead of black people we
already got that figured out so now it's
trans and we're pretty young country I
remember I saw someone mention that one
of these intellectual personalities but
all these old countries don't have it
figured out we've led the way of weed
and and we're like a Melting Pot or
whatever so we should give ourselves a
little more credit with dealing with
with like unique issues that not many
other countries face like this
intellectual guy went off on it one time
and I felt good because it was like yeah
[__] can be [__] up culturally here
but if we're also have like a unique
like people rubbing against each other
that aren't rubbing against each other
in other countries and [__] like that so
do you think and we have to be up front
America has to be upfront about its
racism dude if you go to Europe
they exported their racism so like they
just did it in another country and then
they go like I don't have to do it you
have to figure that's better okay I
don't want to bring racism home with you
yeah you don't want to practice every
day yeah Canada you can't immigrate
there unless you have like a bachelor's
degree like it's just possible to become
like a citizen and so they figured out
they said like let's just put hard
stipulations early and then we'll just
be really nice to everyone for the rest
of life and then people like okay it's
easy to be nice to someone with the
bachelor degree yeah I'm being nice to a
Mexican without a bachelor's degree yeah
that's [__] that's the game on yeah
they don't get any of your references I
hate when Mexican people act like they
don't understand you and it's like I
know you understand me you're just you
don't want to play the game yeah but
it's like fair enough you know I I feel
like they get to do that because I feel
bad for them so I'm like yeah [__] over
these white people oh they're good to be
like just that [__] I don't know what
you just said I just said I don't
understand
yeah I don't know Spanish I know kitchen
a little bit of kitchen Spanish because
I'm a poor white I'll poor whites now A
little yeah
but if I if I was a I could like just
another cuss word of course
the direction of the conversation I
thought there was 200 uh people in the
alley at kill Tony when I got home my
girlfriend was like what is the inside
of the club look like and I'm like I
don't know and uh there's a guy from a
restaurant nearby that was dragging a
trash can a Mexican guy a little Mexican
guy has an apron and I thought it'd be
so [__] funny somehow I just found
his life at the stage oh yes I work here
hello and just crushed he's like yeah
God Secret Show come on the same outfit
with the mom
and he's legitimately funnier than I
would say 175 of the 200 people that
were standing back there you yell at
anyone yeah it is because of the intent
but if you're trying to do it then
they're yeah that's harder because it's
like you're not there's this guy at my
work who's Hispanic and he jokes around
a lot but he has demeanor like he's not
joking and when you when there's a
language barrier it really
[__] it's like in what way does he
joke though he'll be like he'll grab
something be like don't touch like he's
yelling at you and then like five
seconds later he was like like he's
laughing I'm like dude you can't like I
think you're like being threatening
towards me I don't want to piss you off
so the Mexican accent is trending to you
no he's aggressive you know what I mean
or maybe maybe it is maybe it's my bias
I think Mexicans are great
um I think it's easy to be nice to
Mexicans I agree they're very very hard
yeah I think it's better to not [__]
over I think the reason why there's so
many Hispanic immigrants is because we
[__] over their country so we kind of
deserve it
um but yeah I mean if we want them to
stop coming we should just make sure
their countries are doing fine and we're
not we're using their countries for like
bananas and grapes how did the Alamo end
did Mexico win
they did but but they the whole thing
was that the Texas held out for yeah of
course that's the history Houston was
not involved William B Travis was I
think the famous one awesome and Davey
Crockett may have died in the Years
died in the end [__] up I can't bring
a gun to the Alamo Drafthouse
it's like I thought this is history here
I want to see Batman Mexicans are
allowed that's because we lost yeah
Mexicans don't need it do you think
Mexicans go to the Alamo and do you
think like people look at them funny
like it's the one place it's okay to be
racist to Mexicans well I mean it's in
San Antonio so I don't think that's kind
of sucks
yeah I I heard it sucks I haven't been
that's not great I think maybe I went
when I was younger America has so many
things that don't suck like Grand Canyon
Statue of Liberty like there's [__] that
does not suck it lives up to the hype
but [__] Alamo like dude that was a
fort built in the 1800s it's gonna be
like three stories Max American
landmarks themselves what they consider
an American landmark or what they
consider old in the west like as far
west you get is so like being from
Boston and be like yeah this seems like
50 years old isn't that so ancient
you're like no dude it's like very my
parents live in a house it's just cool
that there was a fort where people
wanted to take it over and we can just
stand there and be like hey it's not
that hard like they were trying to do
this I'm gonna do some other show when I
get in there with a gun and say I refuse
to get out here until you let me do five
minutes
someone would shoot you they would
someone's packing I have snuck a gun in
there I'd open mics I've threatened to
like gun violence at Several of them so
I'll never be able to own a gun because
it's like if they come find one in my
house it'll be like a credible threat
but because that's what we do is we look
through podcasts to make sure that all
people deserve guns like we don't even
have background checks for felonies
that's true
what kind of gun would you guys get all
right do any of you have a gun I have
one yeah Sam definitely has that I don't
know oh damn I got a few dude I dude Sam
when he kicked that guy out of your show
the other day it was so like it's
there's guys that can deal with guys
hand on the chest said buddy you gotta
get out of here just kind of lightly it
was like you saw that yeah I know I
didn't know you saw it dude it was an
incredible display of door guys yeah he
knows how to handle a man's body yeah
it's just like there's sometimes you
just have that confidence or like
posture like I'm ready to go okay yeah
like they're speaking the language like
okay this is what's happening yeah it's
like a Jedi mind trick sort of just be
like you're speaking their language it
was uh it was a really good display it
needed to happen yeah it was good that
guy was crazy so crazy did you know all
of what was going on so well you know
most of the verbal stuff so I don't know
if I told you but he was Google
searching did you hear that part yeah it
is canceled yeah
he said he said said hey like for people
that hate liberal stuff as they use the
language of liberals and you don't care
so much about who's canceling he said
Hey Siri is is Gandhi canceled and then
he turned around to the Indians to the
Indians and was pointing at his phone
and she was so uncomfortable yeah and
then he like made eye contact with me
and then I was like are you okay and
then he was like I don't know what he
said but I was like all right come on
let's go yeah wait what was he so
concerned with so we were doing the
dating show and there were like three
sick people Sikh people that came up and
uh we asked like who do you hate or
something like who do you who's like a
I forget what the question was yeah God
came up and she was like he's actually a
bad guy the guy no no what happened was
she said she was sick and then he said
so you hate Gandhi does that mean you
hate Gandhi and then she was like
yeah or whatever and then he asked that
yeah he heckled yeah yeah maybe that is
how it happened I thought Gandhi just
came up and she said what kind of
everyone knows yeah it's like when John
Lennon comes up everyone has to be
puddled with kids or something he slept
naked with kids I didn't realize he said
that but then eventually it was like
Googling it and then it was like
Gandhi's racist or something yeah and
then he was like uh hey uh is this true
and he was like making it a big deal
like everyone like should know about
this yeah and I was like dude shut up or
something it's like oh you're calling me
a racist I don't think I ever called him
yeah he didn't call him racist you
caught him a snowflake well he said he
said he said are you calling me racist
he never called a racist you're like
well you did something you did say yeah
why are you offended yeah and I noticed
like I told Alyssa when I got home it's
like he can tell how I'm just like been
doing the road a lot because he didn't
even have I was like awkward like what
the [__] I gotta handle this weird guy
and hanza just went right at him like
[__] you you're a piece of [__] I'm like
not afraid of you you're an idiot and I
was just like damn confidence it is
being in random ass vices and having to
deal with like the most mentally ill
people ever just like going right at him
because I was just sitting there being
like I'm just trying to get one funny
line so that if this gets like cut into
a real I'll be part of it that was like
my whole mindset yeah
do you have anything kind of holding you
back when some something that happens do
you think and yeah my intelligence and
my wit do some people are so dumb yeah
no but I'm thinking like do you think
like I don't want to do like it's gonna
mess up the show or like do you think
about it in advance but when it gets to
a certain point you have to like you
give them some rope because some people
do just like Teeter on the edge of being
too much of a problem they come back but
then sometimes you just be like this
guy's literally taking over the [__]
show and the show is back to normal
after like yeah I I thought it wouldn't
because sometimes that [__] happens but
eventually we're getting like Laughs
Again as if it was back to the normal
one he wanted to argue about it like he
wanted to be like oh my God Gandhi we
got to bring him back like he was trying
to bring Gandhi back or something yeah
in the middle aggressive based on his
look I thought he was there like for as
a fan of you like I don't know just
basically like it was like a kill Tony
fan so it was weird that it was getting
so antagonistic with you because I was
just like don't you get where he's
coming from like we're all just goofing
and he was watching the show for like an
hour yeah yeah that's that's the crazy
part is like I think he just finally had
either too many to drink or whatever
yeah you know what's funny is uh Jenna
Jim Jenna and her mom yeah Julie they
said that that night they saw him he was
staying at their hotel
that's good yeah the tale of this guy
yeah she said he still looked angry is
what they said I think he's always angry
he's gonna get pulled next week he's
gonna go up and be like it's gone again
what was his ethnicity was he awake he
was a white soul patch sort of
Nickelback type guy yeah he was like a
Nickelback white he's an antifa
see he was under iq85 so he's not even
doesn't have a political if you put that
graph of the political Spectrum in front
of him he would just like piss on it he
doesn't understand like I don't know I
don't even mean to that guy he's just
simple yeah he's just like he's mad at
whatever he's mad at his that's what he
needs to know he's canceled yeah because
he's so susceptible to the larger forces
yeah I just need what if he was like
genuinely just curious his Gandhi
canceled like you're freaking out he's
like oh my God yeah I was thinking
something there's some Indians that ate
at my restaurant this morning and waited
on them and they were looking at
pictures of their trip to Texas or when
they moved here and you know I saw one
of them in a cowboy hat and I thought
Indian people when they come to Texas
they love the mega fun of white people
wearing the cowboy hat picture just like
look at me I am a cowboy
that's what they were doing yeah 100
they're just like they have their belly
out yeah dude they're just like look at
this dumb hat
I don't know it's just funny because
it's just like a very cartoonish thing
if you're not from here and you think of
Texas even me from even from
Massachusetts like my mom would take
that picture but the entire world has
that cartoonish view of Texas is the
funniest month yeah I love it I don't
know why I love Indian people in Texas
because they're just living it up if you
if you go to India do you put a ruby on
your forehead and walk around as well
and take pictures look Cowboys honestly
it's not white you know there's a lot of
Hispanic a lot of African-Americans It's
a Good Hat yeah it Shields the Sun the
Ruby thing would be a little different
that's something
why would it be different because they
can't just take it off and put it on
sure you can they got sticky ones no
they're born they're born with a ruby
and they're happy yeah that's the
culture yeah they're like aliens yeah
yeah
damn
you know anyways so what did you think
about the silver Silicon Valley Bank
going under I didn't even hear that made
me wish I would have pulled a loan out
from him first
yeah
selfie that bag no it's a Silicon Valley
Bank that basically well apparently uh
uh Peter Thiel who's like this right
wing shadowy he's gay right gay guy yeah
billionaire was like hey let's start a
run on this bank because we can we can
put them out of business yeah so
apparently he didn't like their politics
or what they were doing or was it an
anti-woke move from Peter thiels I think
it was just like I don't like the
general direction of this bank so it was
probably political you know a Peter
thiel's name I heard this recently and
it's an anagram for the reptile the
reptile yeah that's pretty cool
fascinating he's a gray wolf uh it's
weird there's like crypto.com Arena like
Sofi bank and I'm like these places are
going under like their heads you know I
mean like it's like they're certainly
not big enough to Warrant a [__]
arena in L.A you know what I mean like
they could be valid businesses but
they're not they're definitely in a
bubble if they own the arena but it's so
crazy that we can just create money and
pool money together for this [__]
yeah like Hey we're all gonna do crypto
now and then there's so much money
behind it and
it's just rich people having fun at that
point yeah I mean it makes sense that's
like how most people that are rich are
rich it's like some [__] like that
timing it's like yeah maybe it's our
turn yeah and it's a lot of time like
you meet people with multiple houses and
they just were doing real estate in the
right City at the right time yeah
because there's plenty of realtors that
live in Rhode Island that don't have
four houses yeah man yeah so if you have
enough cash to just buy a lot of
properties that's yeah but the black
dudes make a shitload of money but
that's what Tim Dylan does yeah dude I
heard that he just enjoys like open
houses he likes going to them
it seems like he enjoys like actual
buying and renovating but that's why
he's so good at making fun of liberals
is because like he's like he he
understands them he likes open houses he
likes that kind of yeah that's why Bill
Burr is getting it too because people
like label is right he's like he's a
left he's a very like liberal he's very
left-wing yeah so that's why he like
it's like you're for your favorite
sports team sucks it's easier to talk
[__] on them because you know everything
about them yeah you're just like they
suck right now I wish they were better
that's like yeah yeah being from Boston
when the Red Sox were awful don't you
love the red so he's like yeah but they
[__] do you think it's like easier to
be funny making fun of liberals than
conservatives because like conservatives
when you make fun of them it's like some
basic things like hey you should
probably not treat people like animals
and then liberals it's like look at the
kind of fruit that they're eating or
like the sheets that they have it's like
it's not so serious and not so damning
like if you're making fun of
conservatives you're like your whole way
of life is incorrect but liberals it's
like you're you know like your
affectations are humorous yeah yeah well
that's kind of changing too now because
they a lot of liberals kind of take that
you know people say that all the time
that wokism is like a religion but there
are certain tenets that they have where
it's like if you [__] go against
Trump then you're yeah even if you're a
right-wing at all yeah like or like if
you say something that's like aligned
with Trump all of a sudden you're even
if you're a liberal traditionally you're
like Outcast and so there's a lot of
like those reactions that are really
[__] open for humor which is like
Shane Gillis is that's a lot of his
humor that's another guy I say it's the
right way and you watch his action it's
like it's pretty like left wing yeah it
is pretty good there's a little whole
bit about racism in the south of
football and it's like very like isn't
this [__] up and all this [__] yeah
it's basically just happy about life and
that's what makes them right away yeah
isn't that weird if you can't be in a
good mood you have to be miserable
because like Nick de Paulo now is the
right way and even back in the day with
like the albums that I really like he
had he's like a right wing you know
that's like a regular comedian like he
brings up stuff yeah I mean or like uh
you know when he has to talk [__] and
bring it up on stage well now he's
special I mean I watched it it wasn't
the worst I ever seen But it literally
just like snowflakes they're everywhere
huh like it was like [__] like that I
was like dude I used to think you were
the Best comedian ever yeah you're
literally was like obsessed with him and
now that well once you start doing like
comedy when you're like rich and you
made it then you're like what do people
really need to hear what they need is to
change their whole political belief
Dennis Miller or whatever right yeah
yeah
did you see uh Chris Rock special not
yet I do want to watch it though the end
is good when he's talking about that
slap but like in the beginning it's like
what culture what culture it's like oh
not this again yeah uh I heard they
changed it I didn't watch it yet I heard
Netflix had to change the Will Smith Joe
[__] up the Will Smith joke oh he just
[__] it up in like while he was
telling it live yeah did you see that no
but I heard about it yeah because Brian
Regan did the live special on TV in like
the late 2000s like 2008 yeah so
everyone else thinks this is impressive
dude Brian Regan is the truth yeah it's
pretty good for being live
he said the wrong movie it was like uh
the movie's concussion
oh who gives a [__] Will Smith movies
dude yeah
these are jokes
sure sure
you got more than 19 minutes this time
yeah I did this is
shout out to the guy from Ellis Bullard
who came up to me uh at the buzz Mill
was like I listened to your 1900
apologize it was good thanks man that's
who I do it for for the fans the more
the people that we hang out with the
more talented fans that have cooler art
forms than I have human beings that are
good he's a good guy that Fan's cool I
didn't really know really good yeah
sweet sweet hearts of boys yeah they're
really nice yeah
um hey yeah dude
yeah I mean what do you think
I think that's ended I think I'm sweaty
that was pretty good I think it was
blurred as dope I think another hour is
dope yeah
um okay so last question
uh oh my God someone hates me in that
chat who in the chat hates me dude where
are the hobbits sitting on one side and
the elves sitting like oh my God you do
you guys have more like kind of a high
alpha Vibe on that side yeah we're like
the lower Sam is not enough he's way too
dense yeah you're you're definitely like
Boromir Aragorn like the human the human
I'm a human you're human-coded I have
hobbit feet so I got nailed it I have a
[__] bad Hub and feet fat hairy feet
oh man nice that's impressive yeah it's
good yeah I like to start man you can
walk around look at it silent I get a
plus four and move silently in DND
does hair really help yeah apparently
well they are also smaller you have hair
on the bottom it would imagine if you
had the thick coat of hair on the bottom
of your feet though it'd just be
slippery on wood floors
[Music]
all right thanks you
all right well until it's over yeah
let's see what people said about